factor eight K squared minus 24 K minus
144 now the first thing we can do here
just eyeballing each of these terms if
we want to simplify it a good bit is all
of these terms are divisible by 8
clearly 8k squared is divisible by 8 24
is divisible by 8 and 144 it might not
be as obvious is divisible by 8 but it
looks like it is 8 goes into 144 8 goes
into 14 one time 1 times 8 is 8 subtract
you get a 6 14 minus 8 is 6 bring down
the 4 8 goes into 64 eight times so it
goes into 144 18 times so let's just
factor out an 8 of this and then that'll
simplify our expression lecture give us
a leading 1 coefficient so this will
become this will become 8 times K
squared minus 24 divided by 8 is 3 K -
-18 - 18 now we have to factor this
business in here and remember if
anything has the form x squared plus BX
plus C where you have a leading 1
coefficient this is implicitly a 1 we
have that here in this expression in
parentheses then we literally just need
a and we can we can do this multiple
ways but we need to find two numbers
whose sum is equal to the coefficient on
X so two numbers whose sum is equal to
negative 3 and whose product whose
product is equal to the constant term
and whose product is equal to negative
18 so let's just think about the factors
of negative 18 here let's see if we can
do something interesting so it could be
1 and if it since it's negative one of
the numbers has to be positive 1 has to
be negative 1 and 18 if is if it was
positive and then one of these could be
positive and then one of these could be
negative but no matter what we're either
going to have we're gonna if you if this
is negative and this is positive then
this will be they add up to 17 if you
switch them then they add up to negative
17 so those won't work so either we
could write it this way positive or
negative 1 and the negative or positive
to show that they have to be different
signs so those don't work then you have
positive or negative three and the
negative or positive six just to know
that there are different signs so if you
have positive three and negative six
they add up to negative three which is
what we need them to add up to and
they're clearly positive three and
negative six their product is negative
eighteen so it works so we're going to
go with positive three and negative six
as our two numbers now for this example
just for the sake of this example we'll
do this by grouping will do this by
grouping so what we can do is we can
separate this middle term right here as
the sum of 3k and negative six K so I
can write the negative 3k as plus 3k
minus 6 K and then let me write the rest
of it so we have K squared up here plus
3k minus 6 K which is the same thing as
this over here and then we have minus 18
and then all of that is being multiplied
by 8 now we're ready to group this thing
we can group these first two terms
they're both divisible by K and then we
can group we put a positive sign let's
group these second two terms so then we
have 8 times all the right brackets here
instead of writing double parentheses
brackets are really just parentheses
that look a little bit more serious okay
now let's factor out let's factor out a
K from this term right over there just
in a different color let's factor out
the K here so this is K times k plus 3
and then we have + and then over here it
looks like we could factor out a
negative 6 so let's factor out and do
this a different color let's factor out
a negative 6 over here so plus negative
6 times k plus 3 times k plus 3 so now
it looks like we can factor out a k plus
3 there's a capable of 3 times the K and
then we have a k plus 3 times the
negative 6 so let's factor let's factor
that out so we have this 8 out front
that's not changing so let me write that
in the brackets we're factoring out a k
plus 3 so that we have the k plus 3 that
we factored out and then inside of
that we just have left this K instead of
writing plus negative six I could just
write k minus 6 K minus 6 K minus 6 we
factor out the K plus 3 and we're done
and then we can rewrite this is the way
we were already here it's 8 times the
product of K plus 3 times K minus 6 but
we know from the properties of
multiplication this is the exact same
thing as 8 times k plus 3 times k minus
6 and we are done